and I want to add to the uh the
conversation that we had because it was
unexpected it was one of those things
where you and I are talking in the first
conversation and then you open up about
how you know you almost tried to end
your life and I was shocked taken aback
and also I felt this wave of just
appreciation and a lot of people don't
open up you're that you know since I've
known you you're just sort of this is
this is me and I'm flawed and uh you
know we all make mistakes and we all
have dark times in our lives and you you
speak so openly about it that I you know
when people ask me what's your favorite
podcast episode this has got to be up
there I've done over 300 and I'm like
which shows just shows how much pain
we're all in right like how much we all
suffer to figure out how to make this
work you know we're all really
struggling to figure it out and to to
withhold the truth about what I've
experienced I think would be living a
huge lie